[Music]
okay so to celebrate nobody watching the
olympics right now yeah i figured i'd
bring up this tweet it says uh my friend
sent me this video of this poor skier
slamming his [ __ ] and balls directly
into a slalom gate at high speed and i
have to say it really made me reconsider
the severity of my problems in the grand
scheme of things this is from a past
olympics i believe
watch this again oh the frenchman
dude
run that howl back i know how to hear it
hear it
and you could hear it
run that
[Laughter]
one more time
he came at
[Applause]
[Laughter]
keep playing it and if you're a man you
oh [ __ ]
oh miss ya
[Laughter]
what was that i'll miss you
[Music]
wow the boys took a beating on that one
that guy needs a hug
oh my god that guy's big dinger got
smacked up
his basketball's bouncing around on
there his wiener got cooked
[Laughter]
oh man no one likes their meat
tenderized that man needs a hug oh
monsieur oh miss yours oh
[Laughter]
got their [ __ ] balls beat let's just
say his balls turned into fromage
i'm sorry i keep trying to go crash
because i keep picturing him trying to
be like put together then just go
straight uncouth just [ __ ]
oh man this ball bag is split open oh my
god his junk got [ __ ] rocked steve
holy [ __ ]
jesus that [ __ ] is gonna be hurting yeah
can we get a scream one more time
[Laughter]
that was the most french way to get your
nuts hit
and you could hear it
you could hear it
you could feel it wow oh miss yeah yeah
so nobody is watching the winter
olympics yeah i don't give a sign nobody
is watching that should that actually
should be the new slalom event it's not
going around
the sloan it's hitting
yeah how many can you hit and they're in
a straight line just do it through the
pain
yeah like all the guys are just they're
like those crazy dudes on tick tock they
get hit in the nuts that's that guy but
this is his event yeah every time he
hits it
oh all the slalom poles are set up in a
single line yeah and you just gotta go
someone's gonna clip that very nicely
it's like ski jumping you gotta go down
in that position yeah
it's like it's so steep downhill that
you're like this and it's just
and all it is is just going until you
bail there's literally 500 of those
poles and he's going all the way 67 68
69 what a number and 73 oh and he pulls
off to the side he's just
yeah
he just falls to the left yeah oh
monster
damn you know what they should do
they should like if you had like a
terminal illness and you knew you were
gonna go would you rather like go in a
hospital or would you rather just like
go off a ski jump like over
like a [ __ ] ridge on a mountain and
just die like that
yeah um
i don't think that would be as fun as
you think it would be
i don't think dying in the hospital i
mean dude just do a [ __ ] just like
you know
get a medical like
uh injection medical
assisted injection of heroin okay like
before you go down oh so do that right
before you go yeah yeah and just dap
everybody up like [ __ ] sucks it's
ending like this yeah better this than
[ __ ] with that weird jello and apple
juice am i right yeah everyone's like
yeah he's smoking he just
yeah yeah you don't have to see that oh
oh yeah you're you're thinking about
like just onto a cliff like onto just
rock no no no
i mean like no i was thinking like 200
feet above a like beautiful ocean or
lake i mean or something like a river
yeah you know you're gonna hit a tree or
some [ __ ] like yeah you're gonna go yeah
brutal but like it will last maybe a
second yeah like you launch high enough
so that like you know it's k it's like a
whole thing yeah they they determine it
scientifically it's like no cash cash
was thinking sorry to interrupt but cash
was thinking that you would do it like
just on a small jump so you'd get a
little bit of air and then you would
just die from the blunt force of
tumbling rocks as you're as you're
rolling down
not that steep of a cliff yeah and it
just takes a really long time to die
yeah oh
[Music]
i'd way rather death by crotch post
death by skiing cross post yeah just
boom
yeah this
what is this what's
what's it from
forever
wait play the sound play it sounds
this is what cash was thinking
[Laughter]
[ __ ] that's funny that's good but not
not like that i just meant like off like
like some ski jump in like norway yeah
like yeah yeah you're looking at like a
screensaver before you go
yeah
yeah literally looks like you're jacked
into vr you're like oh my god this is so
i think that's what happens i think your
brain
makes you pass out probably so then yeah
yeah there was that guy that died in the
squirrel suit
oh yeah that's just a vap that would be
a pretty sick way to go because he like
evaporated like he's going so fast you
hit something at that speed you just
yeah yeah it's brutal yeah
well if it's willing you know
you